So today we're going to unpack a
really powerful way of looking
at conflict and control.
You know how it actually works
on the ground.
The source material for this
explainer calls it the three
layers of power.
Let's get into it.
You've heard this line a million
times, right?
People love to drop it into a
conversation.
It makes them sound smart, like
they're seeing both sides of a
really complex issue.
But let's be honest, most of the
time, it's just a way to shut
down the conversation without
anyone having to question what
they already believe.
But what if we stop treating it
like some cynical conversation
ending cliche?
What if we actually took it
literally?
The argument here is that if you
do that, the whole hidden
structure of power just clicks
into place.
It shows you that legitimacy
isn't some moral absolute, It's
something that's constantly
being fought over, negotiated,
often with force.
So yeah, let's use this cliche
not as a dead end, but as a key.
A key that might just unlock the
very architecture of power
itself.
OK, think about the War on
Terror.
The people America was fighting
were technically speaking,
civilians, right?
They didn't wear state
sanctioned uniforms, they didn't
belong to a national army.
They got called all sorts of
things.
Insurgents, extremists, narco
terrorists.
And who was hunting them?
The most professional, best
equipped state funded soldiers
in the world.
This whole thing shows you a
really weird asymmetry.
Terrorism gets defined as
civilians killing other
civilians.
But counterterrorism, while that
ends up looking a lot like
professional soldiers killing
civilians who are fighting back
like soldiers.
And the words, the words we use
to describe all this are
absolutely crucial.
They aren't just descriptions,
they're weapons.
I mean, just look at the
contrast when they commit an act
of violence.
It's terrorism.
It's insurgency extremism.
But when we do something that is
the exact same outcome, well,
that's a precision strike.
That was a necessity.
It was justified.
The result might be identical,
but the label we stick on it
does a complete 180, depending
on who's responsible.
The source material just nails
it with this line.
Language acts like a filter.
It sorts all the violence into
these neat little boxes.
Good violence, bad violence, so
that we don't have to look in
the mirror and see the
uncomfortable reflection of our
own action.
So all of this brings us to the
main event, the central idea of
this explainer.
Drawing on observations from
places like Iraq, we can start
to see power working on three
different layers all at the same
time.
First, you've got layer one.
This is the official state, the
government ministries, the
national police, the flag you
see on buildings, it's the power
you see on TV.
But underneath that there's
layer 2, the parallel authority.
These are the real local power
brokers, the sheiks, the gang
leaders, the smugglers, the guys
whose phone call can get things
done faster than any official
decree.
And then you have layer 3, the
external power, the occupiers,
the coalition forces, maybe even
peacekeepers.
And the crucial thing to get
here is that these layers don't
just sit on top of each other.
They're all there at once,
constantly crashing into each
other, fighting for control.
And this is exactly where things
get so explosive when an
external power.
That's Layer 3 comes in and
kicks the legs out from under
the official state.
Layer one.
It doesn't create stability, it
creates a vacuum, a power
vacuum, and that empty space.
It's the perfect opportunity for
those parallel authorities in
Layer 2 to rise up and make a
grab for real power.
Now you might be thinking, OK,
this makes sense for a war zone
overseas, but what if that same
structure, that same geometry of
power is happening right here at
home?
Let's take this idea from
Baghdad and see what it looks
like in a city like Chicago.
See, the argument is that
America talks about its own
inner cities with the exact same
language it uses for foreign
conflict zones, as if they're
these far off alien places
instead of a totally predictable
outcome of how power is
structured.
And when you actually map it
out, the parallel is, well, it's
pretty startling.
In a major American city, Layer
one is the mayor's office and
the city police force.
Layer 3 is the federal
government, the DEA, the FBI,
Homeland Security, And Layer 2,
while that's the parallel
authority of the street gangs,
the crews, the shot callers who
actually control what happens on
a given block.
It's the same three layer game,
just with different players.
So why do these layer two
groups, whether it's militias or
cartels or street gangs, why do
they even exist?
It's pretty simple, really.
They provide governance where
the official state can't or
won't.
They offer jobs, a sense of
structure protection.
They become, as the source puts
it, gods of small things.
They're the ones you go to for
help with rent or a hospital
bill, or to get revenge.
They act like a government, but
they operate with the raw
brutality of a business.
And this is where the whole
model gets really uncomfortable
because if you follow it to its
logical conclusion, it messes
with our deep seated need to
have clear heroes and villains.
Just think about it.
The official state claims the
exclusive right to use violence,
it collects taxes, and it gets
to define who is and who isn't a
criminal.
Now look at a cartel or any
other powerful layer two group.
It uses violence, it collects
taxes through extortion, and it
definitely defines its own
enemies.
The functions are shockingly
similar.
The only real difference is 1
has official permission and the
other doesn't.
This leads to a really profound
and kind of heartbreaking human
truth.
Both sides mourn their dead with
the exact same sense of
conviction.
Both sides truly believe they
were fighting for their own
people, for what was right.
The grief rhymes because the
belief behind it rhymes too.
And that's what this all boils
down to, really.
All our abstract labels,
terrorist, soldier, extremist,
patriot, they all just dissolve
into a very real, very human
price.
A precision strike sounds clean
and surgical from thousands of
feet up, but on the ground it's
just a suddenly violently empty
chair at a family's dinner
table.
Which leaves us with a final,
and pretty unsettling question.
If every single side is
absolutely convinced of its own
righteousness, then who actually
gets to draw the line between
the hero and the villain?
And what does it mean if that
line isn't drawn by morality at
all, but just by who has the
most power?